[Music]
the loud house is one of the biggest
animated hits of recent years but we
couldn't help but notice the number of
shows that owed something to the popular
cartoon keep watching to the end and
we'll show you some things that will
remind you of the loud house all the way
down to the title if this is your first
time visiting the things then please
remember to give this video a thumbs up
and hit the subscribe button today we're
looking at five shows that copied the
loud house stuck in the middle if you
are as much a fan of the loud house as
we are then you'll know the premise of
the show it's the story of Lincoln mouth
and his ten sisters Laurie Lenny Luna
Luanne Lynn jr. Lucy Lana
Lola Lisa and Louie loud and what
happened to their lives in the town of
royal woods Michigan so there is one boy
and there are ten sisters a pretty large
family right Flo another show that a lot
of the loud house fans accused of
copying it is the Disney Channel's stuck
in the middle that particular program
tells a story of Harley Diaz who lives
in the town of Marsh port Massachusetts
with her six siblings already alarm
bells are ringing but you know how for
instance Luna loud is a wild crazy
out-of-control rucker well in stuck in
the middle
Ethan Diaz is Carly's partner in crime
and an aspiring musician
now although stuck in the middle was
actually broadcast three months before
the loud house that doesn't mean that it
wasn't in some way inspired by it that's
because the loud house was originally
pitched as an animated short all the way
back in 2013 however in fairness there
is one major difference between the two
shows the loud house is animated well
stuck in the middle is live-action
welcome to the Wayne one of the things
that people notice about the loud house
is its rad a distinctive type of
animation show founder Chris Savino had
a very distinctive sort of style and
that style is something that you see a
lot in other cartoons let's take one as
an example
welcome to the Wayne debuted on Nick
comm back in 2014 before being turned
into its own broadcast series in 2017 if
you look at the main characters and see
Melina Ollie Timbers and Sarah lien
Timbers then you don't have to use your
imagination that much to see them
turning up in the loud house there's a
certain look to them which is a little
bit familiar however to give some credit
to welcome to the Wayne there
also a lot of differences for instance
the loud house is a slice of life and is
based on a family Wow welcome to the
Wayne is more of a mystery kind of
cartoon we think that the newer show
also pays homage to other classic
animations of that genre such as
scooby-doo where are you and gravity
falls if anything the program probably
has more in common with gravity falls
especially when you consider that
there's a fair bit in common between
Ollie and Sarah lean and navel and
dipper but even so there's still a
definite comparison to be made with the
loud house The Adventures of napkin man
when we're looking at TV shows that
remind us of the loud house there are a
number of things to consider for
instance the roud house didn't just
emerge from out of nowhere although it
can seem a little bit like that
sometimes the show's creator Chris
Savino had been making animations for a
long time and his style had been seen in
a number of shows that's why we think
that it isn't just shows that were made
after the loud house first came into
existence that owe something to its
overall style one of the programs that
we think could be described as live
house copy is The Adventures of napkin
man if you haven't heard it we will
explain it to you it's a Canadian show
that was shown on CBC and it combines
live-action and animation it involves a
preschool teacher called mr. Anthony who
has to explain emotions and how to deal
with them to his students he does this
with the help of a cartoon superhero
named napkin man who is a man who as his
name suggests is drawn on a napkin and
if you look at the character of napkin
man there's a certain loud house quality
to him you could easily imagine napkin
man making some kind of cameo appearance
in the loud house Elena of avalor
one of the many great things about
cartoons is the opportunities it
provides for skilled actors to use their
voices to full effect if you're a fan of
The Simpsons for instance then you will
know that individual members of the cast
often provide the voices for multiple
characters something like that works out
in the loud house although in fairness
pretty much all the characters have
their individual actors so let's turn it
on its head a little bit there can be a
certain hold on
sort of
happens when you see a cartoon character
and you recognize their voice that
happened to us when we watched Elena of
avalor on the Disney Channel now it
probably won't come as much of a
surprise to you to hear that the voices
of loud twins
Lola and Lana are provided by the same
person actress grey Griffin so we were
rather taken back when we heard some
familiar tones in Elena of avalor you
see she provides the voices for some of
the characters on that show including
dr. Mendoza the original voice of
Lincoln Grant Palmer is in the Angry
Birds movies while Brian's Stepanek who
plays slim jr. voice Magnaflow on the
Cartoon Network mixels too loud there
are many things about the lab house that
are incredibly distinctive whether it's
the overall premise of the very large
family the animation style which pays
tribute to classic newspaper comics
there are a whole range of things that's
when you hear them you think the loud
house but oddly one of the biggest
things is the actual name of the show
one of the things that made us intrigued
by the program was how unusual it was we
have no idea what to expect from it but
we loved it can we think you did too
anyway something that really made us
raise our eyebrows was when DreamWorks
TV premiered a program called - vowed
that in early 2017 firstly the use of
the word loud automatically made us
think of the loud house secondly the
animation style definitely reminds us of
the family that we all know and love if
you look at the characters they
definitely could be residents of the
town of royal woods in fairness the show
itself isn't entirely lifted from the
bat house it's about a couple of kids in
the library who are just well too loud
but we wondered what are the shows you
think Oh more than a little - other
programs and are there any other loud
house coffee's that we've missed tell us
in the comments and that's all for our
five shows that copied the loud house if
you liked it then you should check out
ten hilarious ripoffs of the most
popular cartoon thanks for watching and
don't forget to subscribe
[Music]